nous passons à la question de notre
collègue madame and chain larcher pour
le long de l'est républicain merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics
elle est un cri d'alarmé des
collectivités locales qui votent en ce
moment leur budget
la france accuse un déficit public bien
supérieur à celui de la moyenne de
l'union européenne
elle est l'un des trois états membres
avec le portugal et la croatie qui
présente à la fois d'aider qui
déséquilibre macroéconomique et un
déficit public jugés excessifs
un tableau qui ne vous empêche pas de
vous féliciter d'un déficit de trois et
demi pour cent pour cette année 2015 due
essentiellement à la baisse des
investissements des collectivités à
hauteur à hauteur de 4,6 milliards
je vous rappelle que françois hollande
avait annoncé en 2012 un déficit de 1,3
pour cent pour 2015
comment pouvez-vous vous réjouir d'un
chiffre qui n'est d'ailleurs pas le
résultat des efforts de l'état mais
d'une ponction décidé arbitrairement sur
les budgets des collectivités locales le
complément étant dû à un environnement
économique favorable que nos voisins eux
ont su mettre à profit pour réduire
leurs déficits publics les collectivités
territoriales ont dégagé un excédent de
700 millions d'euros en 2015
c'est dû notamment à la baisse de leurs
dépenses d'investissement résultant de
la baisse drastique des dotations de
l'état
à ce sujet nous nous étonnons des
chiffres transmis ce matin aux communes
par la direction générale des
collectivités territoriales la baisse de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
apparaît encore bien plus importante que
l'année dernière
alors alors que la diminution annoncée
par le gouvernement devaient être
équivalente
on parlait même de réduction monsieur le
ministre comment expliquez vous ces
chiffres transmis par la direction
générale des collectivités locales
avez-vous pour objectif de continuer de
présenter des bilans établis sur le dos
des collectivités locales la parole est
à monsieur christian eckert secrétaires
d'état chargés de budget merci monsieur
le président messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
commencer par un élément technique
pardon de temps en temps il faut aussi
accepter d'en faire c'est que les
transferts financiers entre l'état les
collectivités territoriales au sens du
déficit public sont neutres au sens du
déficit public mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs si vous
supprimez une dépense d'un côté et une
dépense de l'autre vous avez un résultat
qui a une somme nulle
messi mais sam je réitère ma proposition
je réitère ma proposition monsieur
cherche madame la présidente de la
commission des finances de venir devant
votre commission des finances devant
votre commission des finances pour nous
expliquer sur cette question alors vous
m'interrogez madame la sénatrice sur le
futur les l'excédent qui a été réalisé
que vous avez souligné de 700 millions
d'euros par les collectivités
territoriales
effectivement une nouveauté par rapport
à un déficit qui était de l'ordre de
quatre milliards et demi l'année
dernière mais les chiffres sont ceux là
vous pouvez vous agitez ils sont cela
c'est cet excédent montre
qu'effectivement il existait une
certaine capacité d'investissement qui
n'a pas forcément été mobilisés pour
différentes raisons transfert de
compétences fusion de collectivités
incertitude sur l'avenir c'est ma
conviction je vous invite
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs à regarder les comptes des
collectivités territoriales je lui ai
indiqué en janvier
en janvier je suis prêt demain ce soir
la semaine prochaine à venir chiffres en
main devant votre commission des
finances un débattre de ce sujet